[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody prefers me
feet I'm Sean Evans coming at you from
the Beatrice and in NYC is West Village
why well I might be the worst cook to
ever host a food show in the last couple
of weeks we've been asked our way
through scrambled eggs we've mastered
the art of the buffalo wing and today
we're going to make the best damn steak
and potatoes you've ever seen in your
entire life we're teaming up with Angie
Mar one of the top red blooded meat
maestro's in the entire country today
she's going to give us a crash course
and how to make the perfect steak dinner
nothing left to it but to do it let's go
to the kitchen before we begin can you
kind of break down the cut of meat that
we're working with today and why I have
a stager I survived one of the most
tender delicious cuts on the cow if I
wasn't ready to spend money on this
survive I think that you know hanger
steak first make those are all really
flavorful cuts meat and and they're
perfect for for what we're going to do
careful a lot of people they play with
marinades they play with butter
what are we seasoning with today because
we have the small town is very small
keep it that felt yeah I keep things
really really simple I think that if
we're investing our money and really
great quality meat there's no need for
marinades for me it's just meat salt and
fire
all right let's cook these steaks so I'm
going to start with a just a regular
skillet when you heat it over high heat
I'm going to skews in my baked really
liberally on both sides
why so much fold well a lot of it's
going to come off in a pan in the
cooking process so we want to make sure
that we're good also one of the
important things is to let our meat
temper so this bake has actually been
sitting out at room temperature for
about 30 minutes it's gonna Lau for
better cooking more even cooking and a
little bit different too
all right so I'm going to start with a
little olive oil get a little olive oil
action in there so I put my stakes a
little bit differently a lot of people
will do a hard sear I'm going to
continually flip it and slowly and
gradually fill the color because we're
not going to put me outside of our steak
so well done it's just an excessively
medium rare all the way through what are
the biggest mistakes that people make
when they're making a steak at home not
resting your meat part of the cooking
process is letting our meat rest so
after it comes out of the pan it's going
to continue to cook until it's
stone-cold
our resting time is about half the
amount of time that it was cooked and
about how much time do you think we've
had this cooking I mean this has been
going for about seven minutes so I'm
going to take it out we're going to let
it rest for four all right so we have
the steak resting now it's time to make
some potatoes and we're not making any
regular potatoes these are not basic
potatoes are we no we're actually going
to take some fingerling potatoes we're
going to smash them I've already boiled
these with some salt and some thyme and
a little bit of black pepper and they've
been cooled down and I'm just gonna
smash them so we get a nice even surface
so they Brown up beautifully okay and
I'm actually going to fry these in the
feast chat that was rendered from our
cake I don't really do vegetables
personally but if I was going to do it
because them beef fat
so I'm just going to let them go they're
going to get nice golden-brown and then
we're going to toss them and then finish
them with some herbs it's one of the
better smelling meals that I've had
prepped for me in a long time Angie well
I mean even scrambling eggs oh god be
better right we always want to rest on
me because when it comes out of a hot
pan the juice is inside of it or super
super hot you want the juices to relax
want everything to cool down and just
kind of mellow out and also still
continue to cook a little bit can you
give a lesson on slicing because a lot
of people they stumble when they head to
the finish line
we cut against the grain so the grain of
the meat goes this way we want to cut
against the grain that's how we're going
to tender steak okay what I like to do
is just cut right down the bone so we're
just going to go right here super tender
we always want to make sure that we're
slicing with a sharp knife we don't have
a sharp knife we're just going to
destroy the meat and tear the muscle
fibers you can see here all of my meat
beautifully pink all the way through can
you kind of speak to the beautifully
pink aspect of the state because we have
one of the most active and engaged raw
meat taskforces in the history of
YouTube seems you know every time our
audience is a little bit of pink they
freaked out what do you lose by
overcooking your you lose flavor you're
going to lose moisture and you know to
be quite honest it's like this steak was
aged for 60 days if we were to cook this
well done it's like it's losing all of
that time all of that you know those
beautiful flavors is just going to
dissipate for someone
[Music]
it might look intimidating on paper but
you know what you can slam right through
that thing and like 11 12 13 and that's
15 minutes to now and you have an
amazing meal in front of you the only
thing left to do is to dive in not bad
right
so just salt meet fire
face it really beautiful but again
focusing on the quality of the
ingredient and then potentially because
you don't want too many things to get in
the way you know you just rip right
through that and it's visceral you know
what I mean I feel like I'm connecting
with some caveman roots or something
back there perfectly tender the salt and
then I just you know a crispy thin outer
cap perfection
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]